si aún hay cosas que no están del todo
claras no dudes en preguntar para eso
estamos aquí los hombres y las máquinas
de coser se unen para tomar el control
de su anticoncepción este es el objetivo
de este taller organizado por el
colectivo garzón quería dejar de avalar
el sistema de anticoncepción hormonal al
que se somete a las mujeres
es algo que realmente no creo que sea
bueno para el cuerpo femenino quiero
involucrarme para tener algo más
otra cosa es hacer su propia ropa
interior con calefacción el principio
médico de este método térmico es
sencillo si la temperatura de los
testículos sube de 34 a 36 grados la
producción de esperma disminuye con
menos de un millón de gametos por
decilitro de esperma el hombre deja de
ser fértil la técnica llevar una prenda
interior adaptada que aprovecha el calor
corporal manteniendo los testículos
cerca del cuerpo
será necesario adaptar las medidas para
tener un dispositivo adaptado para las
personas
esta es mi primera vez necesito que
todos avancen
tomás se ha aprobado varios métodos
antes de llegar aquí probó primero el
método hormonal
consiste en una inyección intramuscular
profunda es en las nalgas no es práctico
hacerlo uno mismo
se necesita un día fijo cada semana una
dosis de producto y un profesional de la
salud para hacerlo por eso inicie una
transición al método térmico
la ropa interior con calefacción también
tiene sus limitaciones se activa después
de tres meses y se usa 15 horas al día
su eficacia es totalmente verificable
mediante la esperma graba un análisis de
laboratorio que estima el número de
espermatozoides en los testículos alguna
molestia en los testículos no no
francamente estoy bien lo que aprecio es
el intercambio de información como es
con los demás es normal tener tal o cual
sensación tal o cual molestia que
permite estar tranquilos sobre el método
sobre los consejos un momento para
compartir salud
que también compensa la falta de
compromiso de los médicos en el tema
cuando los médicos se decidan a
acompañarnos será mucho mejor para la
prescripción de espermograma la
comprobación de su correcta
interpretación etcétera hoy en día la
asociación carece de medios para
responder a todas las solicitudes y será
necesario que el colectivo médico se
forme en la materia
otro método anticonceptivo la vasectomía
es una operación que consiste en cortar
los conductos deferentes para impedir el
paso de los espermatozoides sin embargo
los franceses son cinco veces más
propensos que hace diez años a
utilizarlo hierro y que es uno de ellos
quería hacerme una vasectomía porque
tenía dos hijos quería más y pensaba en
un método anticonceptivo totalmente
fiable por último está la ligadura de
trompas o la vasectomía sólo que la
ligadura de trompas no es en absoluto la
misma operación es muy dolorosa es
invasiva se necesita una incapacidad
médica de 15 días
sin embargo este método de
anticoncepción permanente sigue siendo
minoritario en francia el 20 por ciento
de los hombres británicos lo utilizan
frente al 1% de los franceses para
pierre louis se trata de un paso hacia
una mayor igualdad
la vasectomía si es feminista de hecho
me doy cuenta de eso el hecho de que
pocos hombres lo hagan es que muchos
hombres no asumen la carga mental de la
anticoncepción
la piedra acompaño a la revolución
sexual de los años 60 creo que la
vasectomía debe ser una segunda
revolución sexual la mujer debe ser
libre en sus decisiones
en el grupo
estefan jordan y todas pasaron dos años
investigando la anticoncepción masculina
una pregunta los ocupó al principio
porque la píldora masculina fácil y
accesible no está todavía en el mercado
la primera razón médica es que cuando un
hombre ingiere testosterona una molécula
que podría bloquear la producción de
espermatozoides es destruida
naturalmente por el hígado pero los
obstáculos sociales y políticos impiden
superar este problema médico
las empresas farmacéuticas nunca
percibieron que había un mercado lo cual
es natural ya que los hombres no están
interesados nunca ha habido ningún
impulso político ni de la izquierda ni
de la derecha por supuesto para los
autores y los métodos disponibles se
utilizan tampoco es principalmente por
las mentalidades que se resisten al
cambio ya que hay siglos y siglos y
milenios de patriarcado detrás uno tiene
la sensación de que los hombres están
dispuestos a replantearse la forma de
seducir a las mujeres
pero que en esta cuestión de la
anticoncepción cool a la no me tocan los
testículos no quieren oír hablar de todo
eso por eso se le llama el último tabú
que es un tabú también basado en
creencias sin embargo ni la erección y
la libido se ven afectadas por estos
métodos sin hormonas